noch ein paar toleranz weihnachten
programm kommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wärest du so gibt der mannschaft für das
glaube ich als aktiver musiker und weil
ein 1100 liter sonderkonzert unser grad
und bis mit kanadischer wahnsinnig viel
was man erreicht hat und die menschliche
stimme ist warm und das berührt so viel
mehr hand liegt damit bereits doch
eigentlich das größte musste heute 15
110 jahren wo alwin da kannst du mir mal
so ist das wenn es um galt schon früh
als wunderkind und so die professorin
krisztina laki prophezeien viele
experten eine weltkarriere
wie geht ein junger mann mit solch einer
erwartungshaltung um davon handelt
dieser film
[Musik]
diese bilden susanne a d
zurzeit fährt den er täglich von bremen
wo er gesang studiert nach bremerhaven
dort hat das sein erstes engagement an
einem open house ausserhalb der schweiz
und wie überall ist der 19-jährige viel
jünger hat seine kollegen
nicht nur konkurrenten oder würde eine
kollegin habe gegenwärtig zu kommen
der westen also in jedem fall sicher
nicht wenn also der sympathie entgegen
von den gleiches macht aber auch anders
geht uns ja auch das obwohl für ihn
neuland bewegt sich eines home in diesem
milieu so locker als würde schon seit
jahren in den opernhäusern dieser welt
ein und aus gehen sie wollen wir heute
kommen haben sie eine wiederaufnahme
probe denn er ist ein super mensch ist
es nicht gelungen ist
alles zu fuß und existenzängste ja also
besser es nahm der fall dass es so
billig rollos eigentlich überall so das
ist eigentlich eh deshalb verstanden
dann zu schweizer halten normal aber
manchmal nicht so gar nicht sogar wird
es sicher andere möglichkeiten vor also
ich bin immer optimist lernt von meiner
familie es klappt ja viele sachen nicht
und ich mache also zunächst das alles
klappt das abitur zum beispiel rhames
einfach dass der dow geklappt und daran
die aus bewusst macht dann alle fertig
gemacht neben wlan alle bestanden dass
das sind so sachen wie man muss wirklich
entscheider und dann das macht dann
wahrscheinlich auch karriere ist dass
man sich wirklich für einfach ganz ganz
fest gesetzt
[Musik]
sein talent hat ihm die aufnahme an die
musikhochschule auch ohne matura möglich
und zu einem engagement in dieser
zeitgenössischen oper von peter maxwell
davies geführt fiel wieder im alter will
ich mit 15 ist praktisch uster - im
internat galerien und einfach ist so ist
kalte wasser geworfen wird die
erstdrucke damals nun hwk so misst die
haie geschätzt wie damals wir haben mit
nacht berühmt und sieht embryos zu
spinnen
man lernt irgendwie damit fertig sein
und man lernt auch das problem im
privatleben sind aber auf der bühne
interessiert dass niemand und ihre
kolleginnen oder kollegen könnten pro
und sagen hör heute bin ich nicht so vor
wenn ich habe probleme zu hause und dass
das stört meere als arbeitskollege will
dass das interessierte proben jemand
werden jeder hasst ihn problem aber sein
muss man stabil sie hat sehr gute
schüler zehn monate ist es her dass er
das home das musikgymnasium in feldkirch
abgebrochen hat und hierher nach bremen
zog
doch oft ist auf konzertreisen in ganz
europa da bleibt wenig zeit für das
studium und sein zuhause
was ist wohnzimmer minister zeil
ja da halte ich mich die meiste zeit
aber ich bin ja auch nur in der nacht
meistens da zum schlafsofa wenig wie
heißt du ganz ruhig
wer einen termin sensibel wenn ich jetzt
aber hoffen dass es so weitergeht wie
bis jetzt also nicht gut die schritt
gemacht und das entwickeln wie gut ihr
volk bevor nicht hoffe dass das konstant
zur pizza grad
das netz viel auf einmal ist aber das
ist immer gute dosis vor folge wenn es
über immer lang alles schnell geht ja
darum habe ich zum beispiel buche als
vorsänger abseits wenig sie kann und
jetzt ziemlich vorbereiter aber
irgendwie kann ab und zu angst das ist
warum so viele frage und ich kann gar
nicht alles bewältigen und du musst noch
mal bis absage das mainzer seite kann
ich vielleicht die eine woche nur vier
konzerten statt sachs konzert an das ist
ein auto also muss lernen dass sie nicht
schlafen kann
es ist außergewöhnlich mit welcher
reifen und professionalität dieser junge
mann im leben steht
aeneas da schon als kind das rampenlicht
liebte und die medien
der 14 jährige zürcher sängerknabe as
rom ist ein ausnahmetalent im
klassischen gesang
wann sollen wir ihn doch sterben
[Musik]
der 14 jährige versuchte jugendlich
glatte stirn in falten zu legen
dramatisch soll es wirken das lied über
die verlorene liebe
[Musik]
wer stiftet es nach erfolg dafür
arbeitet er hat zweimal die woche im
einzelunterricht am konservatorium
winterthur
ich glaube ich habe sehr quartieren
glaube also nicht dass sein team die
heim die fahrer zu machen wir nicht
machen
erinnerung verbinden und dass man der
jugend schon so ein starker berufswunsch
hat und wo es praktisch aus das ist es
wert schon
also ich würde sagen es ist das
vielleicht ist übersprungen haben also
ich bin sehr froh um die sie zwar nicht
jetzt haben wir uns speziell für
jugendliche die leben komplett vermissen
sie das nicht wenn sie mängel blut
gesehen immer in der disco sagt der
konsumiert
doch ausruhen gibt es nicht
in den nächsten monaten stehen weitere
konzern wirft dem programm
in italien ungarn und den usa mit thomas
[ __ ] einem international erfolgreichen
tenor hob der as rom
aber erstmal für ein liederabend in der
heimat nicht noch krank werden von der
premiere gerichtet
[Musik]
ich mag ich ein bisschen jahres
wahrscheinlich ist es dass schweizer
das ist ein anderes als das hochdeutsche
dass du wirklich versucht indem in diese
diese form des iso du kannst ihn gerne
aufziehen oben airbus
das möchte ich nicht aber da das nicht
deshalb bis hin zu tief was habt ihr
[Musik]
aber ja ich sehe schon dass das kommen
von der stadt die du schießt es wird der
kehle auf die kinos aber entspannt
bleiben
ja in einer wenn das ein kick off ist
soll der locker bleiben also dass du
nicht schließt ja nicht ich nicht hier
zu packen sondern jeder weise als
gemalte kennst du wieder nicht das ist
[Musik]
die wichtigste bezugsperson neben thomas
[ __ ] ist die ungarin krisztina laki die
sopranistin hat alle wichtigen papieren
ihres fachs gesungen unter anderem auch
an der mailänder scala
heute unterrichtet sie auf der ganzen
welt
ungefähr karotte es auch sehr gut für
die haut habe ich gelegen
neben dem reinen gesanglichen stets
ihrem schützling auch in fragen der
keine planung zur seite dann habe ich
eine anfrage aus italien ich könnte da
senioren in einem musikfest ist zwar ein
konzert es ist noch nicht klar was in
peru unbedingt irgendwelche italienische
sache mit kameras
es wäre vielleicht eine weile aus
liebestrank unterschätzen
also sie haben meine aufnahmen gehört
und sie dachten ich habe eine schöne
höhe aber auch eine profunde tiefe ja
sie nach die solle beide asien lernen
und dann schauen sie was zu was sehr gut
ist und du willst du ja ja ja
jurijs sagen dazu aber ein st
thema zu machen
[Musik]
nein
und er ist nicht in meiner wohnung wir
warten jetzt kuchen
luisa eckardt ist 27 jahre alt sie
studiert an derselben hochschule wie
eines home trotz altersunterschied
verstanden sich die beiden auf anhieb 8
[Musik]
doch der war sein ruf eilt ihnen schon
voraus und wir waren alle sehr gespannt
ihn einmal live kennenzulernen und er
hat uns nicht enttäuscht sein erstes
wirklich ok sein ich will mich doch dass
er ja quasi irgendein wunderknabe ist
und einfach in seinem alter schon
unglaublich gut singt und einfach sachen
sind die man in seinem alter noch nicht
singen sollte oder kann und er kriegt
eben und das stimmt dieser ein wunder
wirken
ich würde sagen ja ich möchte sein alter
so sinken gott hilfe
ich muss dafür richtig hart arbeiten und
er kann das einfach toll
hast du die ganze zeit ja es muss ja
seine zarte schokolade soll ja nicht
gerne kuchen werden
[Musik]
hatte jung gefühlt mit europa in
verbindung setzen szenische macht
nein ich mache der weise aus dem ich
mache das und warum sie mit einem router
bacher also mein letzter zeit später sei
das neben die person muss also über mich
glaube ich habe hier die ich liebe dich
und dann habe ich hier schon so oft
gesagt ich liebe dich das spezielle
momentan jemanden in der schumann liiert
den sie viele liebe und schmerz nie
versucht und was jeweils kreditinstitut
erfolg hat also eine ganz unerfahrene
sicher aber fällt also da jeder mensch
lebt glaube das ist die äußere natur und
es gibt leute die sagen über mich und
das weiß auch werder seit ich kann das
nicht sicher dass das in ihk erfahrung
das ist ganz viel mit der bi will
offenbach aber das mit acht seine singen
und mit weniger erfahren wenn sie die in
der letzten märz kommt also immer kurz
spiel
das ist und es für geschichte es nicht
weil wir die lehren hat man seit anja k
einen sänger muss immer elegant sein
in wädenswil wuchs auf der teenager auf
alles eine antwort hat hier gibt er
heute abend sein erstes grosses solo
konzert in der heimat
vielleicht finden sich in dieser idylle
die wurzeln seiner selbstbewussten
persönlichkeit als komisch wenn ich
jetzt hier zu sein zu hause war vier
stunden vor dem konzert das um sein kann
ist haben die letzte probe in der sich
der vater hat gekocht
finanziell macht das angst dazu bleibt
und sich zudem ein besonderes machen mit
kolleginnen und kollegen
zusammenzukommen mal eben etwas was nur
entspannen scherz machen mit 15 saisons
war wie das wetter mitmacht revision
muss ich das jetzt mache für die musik
des opfers also eigene wenn ich meine
sinne kann im lachen dann weiß ich es
ist sogar schneller fahren so ist eine
ganz ordentliche weil man hätte das
große fokussierung auf das ziel ist dass
ich christ entscheidende das mit sehr
hat sie das gewurmt und 400
das hat man dann müssen sie findet im
monat 1 fck tisch sitzen wenn schaltet
das getriebe ein zweiter plan also
besonders entwickelt wenn du jetzt so
selbst die queen war gospel ernst so
vieles wo du später irgendwann schießen
nein
so
das ist kein spiel ja erst einmal nichts
dritte macht situation des level ist
erste große konzert daheim gar dass er
so schnell wie ich sie die heizung sie
jetzt ans herz legen wo weit weg sei
aber auch mal ganz neu in ganz kroatien
nervös machen
20 minuten traf
[Musik]
das wunderkind ist erwachsen geworden
die erwartungen an als home zählt hohe
seine eigenen ziele östlich talent
charakter umfeld alles scheint zu
stimmen und so füllt er vielleicht schon
bald die konzertsäle von los angeles
über paris bis nach shanghai
[Musik]